here we are down to the final sprint
three to go and we're going to take some
of the last three maybe two of the last
three to talk a little bit about stuff
having to do with probabilistic
approaches use of probability and
artificial intelligence now for many of
you this will be kind of a review
because I know many of you learned about
probability over this hand table and
every year since then but maybe we'll
put another little twist into it
especially toward the end of the hour
when we get into a discussion of that
which has come to be called belief nets
but first I was driving in this morning
and I was quite astonished to see as I
drove in this thing here and my first
reaction was oh my god it's the world's
greatest hack and then I decided well
maybe maybe it's a piece of art so I
like to address the question of how I
could come to grips with that issue
there's a distinct possibility that this
thing is a consequence of a hack
possibly the result of some kind of art
show and in any of that some sort of
statue appeared and statues don't
usually appear like that so I've got the
possibility of thinking about how all
these things might occur together or not
occur together so the natural thing
is to build myself some sort of table
and keep track them to keep track of my
observations so I have three columns at
my table
I've got the possibility of a statue
appearing a hack having occurred and
some sort of art show and so I can make
a table of all the combinations of those
things that might appear and I happen to
have already guessed that they're going
to be eight rows in my table so it's
going to look like this and this is the
set of combinations in this row where
none of that occurs at all and down here
is the situation where all of those
things occur except for all it's
possible that we can have in that Art
Show and and have a hack be a legitimate
participant in the art show that's why
we have that final row then we have all
manner of combinations in between so
those are those combinations then we
have FFT t f f TT f TF t f TF t so it's
plain that the number of rows in the
table for these binary possibilities is
2 to the number of variables and that
could be that can be a big number in
fact I'd love to do a bigger example but
I don't have the I don't have the
patience to do it anyhow what we might
do is in order to figure out how likely
any of these combinations are as we
might have observed the area outside the
Student Center the rest of campus over a
long period of time and keep track what
happens on a thousand days or maybe a
thousand months or a thousand years I
don't know the trouble is these events
don't happen very often so the period of
time that I use for measurement needs to
be fairly long probably a day is not
short enough ache
saying keep track of and keep a tally of
how often I see these various
combinations so this one might be for
example 405 this one might be 45 this
one might be 225 this one might be 40
and so on and so having done all those
measurements kept track of all that data
then I can say well the probability that
at any given time period some one of
these things occurs will just be the
frequency or the number of tallies
divided by the total number of tallies
so that would be a number between zero
and one so that's the probability so
that's the probability for each of these
events and it's readily calculated for
my data and once I do that then I can
say that I've got myself a joint
probability table and I can perform all
manner of miracles using that joint
probability table so let me perform a
few of those miracles while we're at it
there's the table and now what I want to
do is I'm just going to count up the
number of row are coming to count up the
probability in all the rows where the
statue appears so that's going to be the
probability of the statute appearing so
I'll just check that check off those
four boxes there and it looks like the
probability of a statute appearing is
about point three five five in my model
I don't think it's quite that frequent
but this is a classroom exercise right
so I can make up numbers that I can make
up whatever numbers I want now I could
say well what's the probability of a
statue occurring giving the given that
there's an art show well I can limit my
tallies to those in which art show is
true like so in that case the
probability just zoomed up so if I know
there's an art show there's a much
higher probability that this that the
the statue will appear and if I know
there's a hack as well as a art show
going on goes up higher still 2.9 what
we can also do other kinds of things for
example we can go back to the original
table and instead of counting up the
probability that we've got an art show
going on we can the probability we've
got a statue as we just did we're going
to calculate the probability that there
is a art show I guess that would be that
one and that one
not that one but that that one so the
probability there's an art show is one
chance intent or we can do the same
thing with a hack in that case we get
that one off that went on robbed that
went on that one
so the probability of a hack on any
given time period is about 50/50 so I've
picked up this little demo so that does
the ends of all these things it could do
or is to with a little more work but
these are just the ends of these various
combinations but you can ask more
complicated questions like for example
you could say what is the probability of
a hack given there's a statue and that
would be limiting the calculations to
those rows in which the statue thing is
true and then the and then what I get is
0.78 1 now what do you think the
probability that it would be a hack
would what would happen to the
probability that it's a hack if I know
that there's an art show well I never go
up or down i well let's try it I went
down so that's sort of because the
existence of the art show sort of
explains why they why the by the statue
might be there now just for fun I'm
going to switch to another situation
very similar the situation here is that
a neighbor's dog often barks it might be
because of a burglar it might be because
of a raccoon sometimes as a burglar and
a raccoon sometimes the damn dog just
barks so let's do some calculations
there and calculate the probability that
the it's a raccoon probably the raccoon
is true some of what we did last time it
looks like on any given night it's a
kind of a wooded area is a high
probability of raccoon showing up and
then the dog then that we can ask well
what is the what is the what is the
probability of the dog barking given
that a raccoon
shows up well in that case we want to
just limit the number of rows to those
we're at raccoon or where the dog is
barking looks like the probability of
the dog barking knowing nothing else is
about three seven that's now but now we
want to know the probability of the
raccoon thus this these guys here need
to get checked these are off so that's
the probability of a raccoon I was that
I get that right sure less probability
of a burglar sorry I was too hot so let
me go back and calculate I want to get
the probability of a raccoon that's true
false true false true false true
so the probability of raccoon a good
night as I said before is 0.5 but now
what's that what happens that
probability if the dog if I know the dog
is barking well all I need to do is
limit my rows to those where the dog is
barking those bottom four and I'll click
that there and you notice all these
tallies up above the median law the
midpoint of going to zero as I'm only
considering those cases where the dog is
barking in that case the probability
that there's a raccoon just the number
of tallies over the total number of
tallies it's gee I guess it's 225 plus
50 divided by 370 that turns out to be
point seven four three
so about 75% of the time the dog barking
there's a counter for well the
probability that a raccoon under those
conditions is is pretty high and now
once again I'm going to ask well what is
the probability of a raccoon given that
the dog is barking and there's a burglar
and guess what will happen there we did
this once before with the with the
statute probability first went up and we
saw the statue and then went down we
another explanation here's this one here
Wow look at that it went back to its
original condition its operatory
probability so somehow the existence of
the burglar and the dog barking means
that the probability of raccoon is just
what it was before we started this game
so those are kind of interesting
questions and there's a lot we can do
when we have this table by way of those
kinds of calculations and in fact the
whole miracle of probabilistic inference
is right in front of us it's the table
so why don't we go home well because
there's a little problem with this with
this table with these two tables that
I've shown you by way of illustration
and the problem is the problem is that
there are a lot of ropes and I had a
hard time making up those numbers I
didn't have the patience to wait and
make observations that would take too
long so I had to kind of make some
guesses and I could kind of management
manage it with with eight rows those up
there I could you know put in some
tallies it wasn't that big a deal so I
got myself those all those eight numbers
up there like like that and similarly
for the art show calculations produced
eight numbers but what if I added
something else to the mix what if I
added the day of the week or what I had
for breakfast each of those things would
double the number of rows of their
binary variables so if I have to
consider the possibility that if I have
to consider ten influences all working
together then I have two to the tenth I
have a thousand numbers to deal with and
that would be hard but if I had a
project probability table that I can do
these kinds of miracles but David I
could have this little projector now
please
I just want to emphasize that although
we're talking about probabilistic
inference and it's a very powerful tool
it's not the only tool we need in our
bag trouble with most ideas artificial
intelligences if they're hardcore
proponents think that they're the only
thing to do and probabilistic inference
has a role to play in developing a
theory of human intelligence and it
certainly has a practical value but it's
not the only thing and illustrate that
point I'd like to imagine for a few
moments that MIT were founded in 1861 BC
instead of 1861 ad and if that were so
then it might be the case that there
would be a research program on what
floats and this of course would be an
experimental problem in experimental
physics and we can imagine that those
people back there or the in that early
MIT would be experimentally minded try
some things I didn't know that what
happened it looks like chalk floats
here's a rock now I didn't float here's
some money doesn't float here's a pencil
now it doesn't float here's a pen here's
a piece of tinfoil I got from Kendra
that floats
that's a metal the other stuffs metal
too now I'm really getting confused
here's a little wad of paper here's a
self oh no I
I've tried actually I've tried that
before they don't float and they also
don't work afterward either well I don't
need to do any of that in the in the MIT
of 1861 ad and Beyond because I know
that our committees worked us all out
and all I have to do is measure the
volume of the stuff divide that by the
weight and if that ratio is big enough
then the thing will float but back in
the old days I would have to try a lot
of stuff and make a big table take into
account such factors as how hard it is
how big it is how heavy it is whether
it's alive or not most things that are
alive float
some don't fish doubt for instance so
we'll be foolhardy to do that that sort
of probability probabilistic inference
on the other hand there are lots of
things where I don't know all the stuff
I need to know in order to make the
calculation I know all the stuff I need
to know in order site or something
floats but not all the stuff I need to
know in order for example to for example
to decide if the child of a Republican
is likely to be a Republican there are a
lot of subtle influences there and
there's the case that if that the
children of Republicans and the children
of Democrats are more likely to share
the political party of their parents but
I don't have any direct way of
calculating whether that will be true or
not I think all I can do in that case is
what I would have done over here is
don't do some measurements get some
frequencies take some take some
snapshots of the way the world is and
incorporate that into a set of
probabilities that can help me determine
if any given parent is a Republican
given that I've observed the voting
behavior of their children so
probability has a place but it's not the
only tool we need and that is an
important preamble to all the stuff
we're going to do today
now we're really through because this
joint probability table is all that
there is to it except for the fact that
we can't either record all those numbers
and it becomes quickly a pain to guess
at them there are two ways to think
about all this
we can think about these probabilities
as probabilities that come out of
looking at some data that's a
frequentist view of the probabilities or
we could say well we can't do those
measurements so I can just make them up
that's sort of a subjective view of
where these probabilities come from and
in some cases there's a there some
people like to talk about natural
propensities like in quantum mechanics
but for our purposes we either make them
up or we or we do some tallying trouble
is we can't deal with this kind of table
so as a consequence of not being able to
deal with this kind of table a gigantic
and
three has emerged for dealing with
probabilities without the need to work
out work up this this full table and
that's where we're going to go for the
rest of the hour and here's the path
we're going to take we're going to talk
about some basic review of basic
probability then we're going to move
ourselves step by step toward the
so-called belief networks which make it
possible to deal to make this a
practical tool so let's let us begin the
first thing is the basic probability let
us say basic and basic probability all
probability flows from a small number of
axioms we have the probability of some
event a has got to be greater than 0 and
less than 1
that's axiom number 1 things have a
probability of being in a binary will
things have a probability of being true
some have probability being false but
the true event doesn't have any
possibility of being anything other than
true so the probability of true is equal
to 1 and the probability of false the
false event the false condition has no
possibility of being true so that's 0
then the third of the axioms of
probability is that the probability of a
plus the probability of B minus the
probability of a and B is equal to the
probability of A or B yeah that makes
sense right
I guess it would make more sense if I
didn't switch my notation in midstream a
and B so those are the axioms and
mathematicians love to start up that way
and they can derive everything here is
to derive from that
I don't I never can deal with stuff that
way I have to draw a picture and think
of this stuff in a more intuitionist
type of way so that's the formal
approach to dealing with probability and
it's mirrored by and it's an intuitions
intuitions that have to do with
discussions of spaces like so in which
we have circles or areas representing a
and B and to keep my notation consistent
on that goes lowercase so you can think
of those those are spaces of all
possible worlds in which these things
might occur or you can think of them as
sample spaces but in any event you
associate with the probability of a the
size of this area here relative to the
total area in the rectangle the universe
so the probability of a is the size of
this circle divided by the size of this
rectangle in this picture so now all of
these axioms make sense the probability
that a is certain is just when it fills
up the whole thing under no other place
for a sample to be that means it has to
be a so that's probability goes all the
way up to one on the other hand of the
size of a is just a intensional dot and
the chances of landing in that world is
zero and that's the the bound on the
other end so this axiom number one makes
sense in terms of that picture over
there likewise axiom number two what
about axiom number three does that make
sense in terms of all this stuff and the
answer is sure because we can just look
at those areas with a little bit of
colored chalk and so the probability of
a is just this area here the probability
of B is this area here
and if we want to know the probability
that we're in either A or B then we just
have to add up those areas but when we
add up those areas this intersection
part is that it in twice so we got to
subtract that off in order to make this
thing make a rational equation so that
that makes sense an axiom 3 makes sense
just as acts as 1 & 2 did so that's all
there is to basic probability and now is
now you can do all sorts of algebra on
that and it's elegant because it's like
circuit theory or electromagnetism
because from a very small number of
axioms in this case 3 you can build an
elegant mathematical system and that's
what probability subjects do but we're
not going to go there because we're sort
of focused on getting down to a point
where we can deal with that joint
probability table that we currently
can't deal with so we're not going to go
into a whole lot of algebra with these
things just just what we need in order
to go through that network so the next
thing we need to deal with is
conditional probability and whereas
those are axioms this is a definition we
say that the probability a given B is
equal to by definition probability of a
and V I'm using that common notation to
me me ant has is conventional in the
field and then we're going to divide
that by the probability of B you can
take that as a definition and that it's
just a little bit about mysterious
algebra or you can do like we did up
there and take an intuitionist approach
and ask what that stuff means in terms
of a circle diagram and some sort of
space and let's see what does that mean
that means that we're going to restrict
the probability of a to those
circumstances where B is
known to be so and we're going to say
that we've got this part here and then
we've got the intersection of a with B
and so it does make sense as a
definition because it says that if
you've got B then the probability you're
going to get a is the size of that
intersection the pink and orange stuff
divided by the whole of B so it's as if
we restricted the universe of
consideration to just that part of the
original universe is covered by B so
that that makes sense as a definition
and we can rewrite that of course as P
of a and B is equal to the probability
of a given B times the probability of V
that's all basic stuff now we do want to
do a little bit of algebra here and
because I want to consider not just to
two cases but what if we divide the
space up into three parts then we'll say
that the probability of a B and C is
equal to what well one way to lot of
ways to think about that but one way to
think about it is that we are
restricting the universe to that part of
the world where B and C are both true so
let's say that Y is equal to B and C the
inner see the Union sorry the
intersection of B and C where a and B
are both true then we can use this
formula over here to say that
probability of a given probability of a
B and C is equal to the probability of a
and Y which is equal to probability of a
given Y times the probability of Y and
then we can expand that
back out and say that P of a given V and
C is equal to the probability or sorry
times the probability of Y but Y is
equal to probability of B and C like
soul ah but wait B and C we can we can
run this idea on that over that one two
and we can say that this whole works is
equal to the probability of a given B
and C times the probability of B given C
times the probability of C and now when
we look stand back and let that sing to
us we can see that some magic is
beginning to happen here because we've
taken this probability of all things
being so and we've broke it up into a
product of three probabilities the first
two are conditional probabilities so
they're really all conditional
probabilities the last ones conditional
on nothing but look what happens as we
go from left to right a is dependent on
two things B is only dependent on one
thing and nothing to the left C is
dependent on nothing and nothing to the
left so you can sense a generalization
coming so let's write it down
so let's go from here over to here and
say that the probability of a whole
bunch of things X 1 to X n is equal to
some product of probabilities we'll let
the index I run from n to 1 probability
of X the last one in the series
conditioned on all the other ones sorry
the that's probability of I of I minus 1
down to X 1 like so and for the first
one in this product I will be equal to n
for the second one I will be equal to n
minus 1 but you'll notice that as I get
as I go from n toward 1 these
conditionals get smaller the number of
conditional things on condition I get
smaller and and none of these things are
on the left there are only stuff that I
have on the right so what I mean to say
is all of these things have an index
that's smaller than this index none of
the ones that have a higher index or
appearing in that conditional so it's a
way of taking a probability of a whole
bunch of thing of the end of a whole
bunch of things and writing is a product
of probabilities conditional
probabilities so we're making good
progress we've done one we've done two
and now we've done three because this is
the chain rule and we're about halfway
through our diagram halfway to the point
we can do something fun but we still
have a couple more concepts to deal with
and the next concept is the concept of
conditional probability so that's that's
all this stuff up here oops
all this other stuff here is a
definition of conditional probability
and now I want to go to the definition
of Independence
in D and D pence so that's another
definitional deal but it's another
definitional deal that makes some sense
with the diagram as well as well so the
definition goes like this we say that P
of a given B is equal to P of a if a
independent of B so that says that the
probability of a doesn't depend on
what's going on with B it's the same
either way so it's independent he
doesn't matter
so what is that what does that look like
if we try to do an intuitionist diagram
well let's say here's a here's B now the
probability of a given B well let's see
that must be this part here divided by
this part here right so the ratio of
those areas is the probability of a
given B so that's the probability of
this way divided by the probability of
both ways
so what's the probability of a in terms
of these areas well probability of a in
terms of these areas is the probability
let's see if I got this right cuz I got
this upside down the probability of a
given B is the probability of the stuff
in the intersection so that's both ways
divided by the probability of the stuff
in B which is going this way and let's
see the probability of a not conditioned
on anything except being in this
universe is all these hash marks poops
like so divided by the universe so when
we say that something is independent it
means those two ratios are the same
that's all it means in the intuitionist
point of view so it says that this
little area here divided by this whole
area is the same as this whole area for
a divided by the size of the universe so
that's what independence means now
that's quite a lot of work but we're not
done with independence because we've got
conditional independence to deal with
and that too can be viewed as a
definition and what we're going to say
is that the probability of a given B and
Z is equal to the probability of a given
Z what's that mean that means if you
know that we're dealing with Z then
probability of a doesn't depend on B B
doesn't matter anymore
once you're restricted to being in Z so
you can look at that this way here's a
and here's B and here is Z so what we're
saying is that we're restricting the
world to being in this part of the
universe where Z is so the probability
of a given B and Z is this piece in here
that a given B and Z is that part there
and the probability of a given Z is this
part here divided by all Z so we're
saying that the ratio of this little
piece here to this part which I'll mark
that way the ratio of this to this is
the same as the ratio of that to that so
that's conditional independence so you
can infer from these things with a
little bit of algebra algebra that P of
a and B given
Z is equal to P of a given Z times P of
B and Z oh boy that's been quite a quite
a journey but we got all the way through
one two three four and five and now the
next thing is belief Nets and I'm going
to ask you to forget everything I've
said for a minute or two and we'll come
back to it I want to talk about the dog
and the burglar and the and and the
raccoon again and now forgetting about
probability I can say the look the dog
barks if they're if a raccoon shows up
the dog barks if burglar shows up a
burglar doesn't show up because the dog
is barking a raccoon doesn't show up
because a dog is barking
so the causality flows from the burglar
and the raccoon to the barking so we can
make a diagram of that and our diagram
will look like this here's the burglar
and here's the raccoon and these have
causal relations to the dog barking so
that's an interesting idea because now I
can say that well I can't say anything
yet because I want to add a little more
complexity to it I'm going to add two
more variables you might call the police
depending on how vigorous the dog is
barking I guess and the raccoon has
propensity to a knocking over the trash
can so now I've got five variables how
big a probability table am I going to
need to keep my tally straight I'll be
two to the fifth that's 32 but what I'm
going to say is that is that this
diagram this diagram is a statement that
every node in it depends on its parents
and nothing else that's not a descendant
now I need to say that about 50 times to
it because you got to say it right every
node there is independent of every non
descendant other than its parents no
that's not quite right given its parents
every node is independent of all other
non descendants well what does that mean
here's the deal with calling the police
here's its one and only parent so given
this parent the probability that we're
going to call the police doesn't depend
on anything like B R or T it's because
all the causality is flowing through
this dog barking I'm not going to call
the police depend on in a way that's
depend on anything else other than
whether the dog is barking or not
because this guy is this is a parent and
these are not descendents of calling the
police so this is independent of up B R
and T all right so let's go walk through
the others here's the dog the dog's
parents are burger appearing and raccoon
appearing so the probability that the
dog appears is independent of that trash
can over there because that's not a
descendant it is dependent on these
parents how about the trash can it
depends only on the raccoon it doesn't
depend on any other it doesn't depend on
any other non descendant so therefore it
doesn't depend on D B or P how about B
it has no parents so it depends on
nothing else because everything else is
either a non descendant because
everything sorry because B does not
depend B does not depend on R and T
because they're not descendants okay
it's interesting that be might depend on
D and P because those are descendants
okay
so it's important to understand that
there's this business of Independence
given the parents independence given the
parents of all other non descendants and
you'll see why that funny strange
language is important in a minute but
now let's see I want to make a model of
what's going to going to happen here so
let me see what kind of probabilities
I'm going to have to figure out this guy
doesn't depend on anything upstream so
we can just say that all we need there
is the probability that a burglar is
going to appear let's say it's a fairly
high crime neighborhood one chance in 10
one day and ten burglar appears the
raccoon doesn't depend on anything of
the other venice own propensity
so it's probability will say a zero
point five raccoons love the place shows
up about one day and - so what about the
dog barking that depends on the weather
there's a burglar and the other parent
is whether there's a raccoon so we need
to keep track of the probability that
the dog will bark for all four
combinations so this will be the burglar
and this will be the raccoon and this
will be false false true true
oops false false true false false true
true true so let's say it's a wonderful
dog and it always barks if there's a
burglar so that would say that the
probability here is one point zero and
it probably here is one point zero and
if there's neither a burglar nor raccoon
the dog still likes to bark just for fun
so we'll say that's chance of one and
ten and then a case of there's a burglar
let's say that's the burglar there's no
burglar but there is a raccoon
tired of the raccoons say only barks
half the time do these numbers that we
have to add up to one they clearly don't
these numbers don't add out to one what
what adds up to one is this is the
probability that the dog barks and then
the other fed and probability is out
here and these have to add up to one so
that would be 0.9 that would be zero
point zero that will be zero point five
and this will be zero point zero so
because those are just one minus the
numbers in these columns I don't bother
to write them down well we still have a
couple more things to do the probability
that we'll call the police depends only
on the dog so we'll have a column for
the dog and then we'll have a
probability of calling the police
there's a probability for that being
false and a probability for that being
true so if the dog doesn't bark there's
really hardly any chance we'll call the
police so make that zero zero one if the
dog is barking if he darts vigorously
enough maybe one chance in ten here we
have the trash can the final thing we
have to think about
there's the trashcan there's the rather
the raccoon and here's the trashcan
probability depends on the raccoon being
either present or not present if the
trash can the raccoon is not present
probability the trash can is knocked
over by say the wind is one in a
thousand if the raccoon is their mailman
like I always like to go in there so
that's point eight so now I'm done
specifying this model and the question
is how many numbers that I have to
specify well let's see I have a specify
that was that one that one that one that
one that one that's six seven eight nine
ten so I had to specify ten numbers if I
just try to build myself a joint
probability table straight away how many
numbers would have to supply
plus two to the two to the N so it's 2
to the fifth that's 32 considerable
saving by the way how do you suppose I
made that table not by doing all those
numbers but by making this belief
Network and then using the belief
network to calculate those numbers and
that's why this is a miracle
because with these numbers I can
calculate those numbers instead of
making them up or making a whole lot of
tally type measurements so I'd like to
like to make sure that that's true then
I can use this this up this stuff here
to calculate the drug to the full joint
probability table so here's how this
works I have the probability of some
combination let's say the police is the
dog the burglar the trashcan and the
raccoon that's you know some combination
of all the combinations are possible
there will give me an entry in the table
one row but let's see using where
there's some miracle here off this chain
rule let's use the chain rule we can
write that as the probability that we
call the police
given E E T and R and then the next one
in my chain is probability of D given B
T and R and then the next one in the
chain is probability of B given T and R
the next one of my chain is P of T given
R and the final one of my chains chain
is P of R now we have some conditional
independence knowledge too don't we we
know that this probability here depends
only on D because there are no
descendants so therefore we don't have
to think about that and all the numbers
we need here are produced by this
table how about this one here
probability that the dog barks depends
only on its parents B and R so it
doesn't depend on T soap B
in turn depends on what does it depend
on it doesn't depend on anything so we
can scratch those probability of T given
R the other is a probability there but
we can get that from the table and
finally P of R so that's why we went
through all that probability chart
because if we arrange things in the
expansion of this from bottom to top
then we arrange things so that none of
these guys depends on a descendant in
this formula and we have a limited
number of things that it depends on
above it so that's the way we can
calculate back the full joint
probability table and that brings us to
the end of the discussion today but
thing we're going to think about is how
much saving do we really get out of this
in this case in this particular case we
only had it calculate we only had to
devise ten numbers out of 32 what if we
had 10 properties or 100 properties how
much saving would we get then that's
what we'll take up next time after the
quiz on Wednesday
you